literally thriving selling out every
weekend Hawaii Phoenix he was just in
Chicago sold out shows all weekend at
all the best comedy clubs in the world
but his minutes have been a little bit
shaky on the show so we literally have
someone challenging him that goes on
after him every single week that if they
win they become the new full-time
regular on the show what we've learned
is that it makes Hans Kim perform a lot
stronger a lot better because he's
fighting for his life
so with no further Ado sing along if you
know the words this is Hans Kim
[Music]
hey
hey I saw an ad for firefighters on it
and on it it had uh on it had an Asian
dude and a woman
if I'm ever in a fire
and I see an Asian dude and a woman
coming to rescue me
I'm gonna kill myself
would you send the HR department
when you're in a fire you don't want to
see diversity
you want to see a Nazi
thank you
you want to see generations of food
security and white privilege
not an Asian dude and a woman
who's gonna drive the fire truck
[Applause]
tired of all these people trying to make
America into a safe space for white
people
that already exists it's called Europe
you want to drink tea and kiss dudes on
the cheek go back to England [__]
wow there it was
man
I was a little nervous at the beginning
there tripped over the hole I saw an ad
with a fire fire ad it was an ad of the
fireman it was a fireman like oh [__] oh
yeah I mean you fought fought fought
like only a real experienced uh autistic
Asian boy could do
how do you feel like that went Hans I
felt like it went amazing oh [__] okay
am I right people
[Laughter]
love it Hans that is another new minute
it's hard to write a new minute that's a
complete bit the uh what kind of AD will
you say you saw an ad you say it like
you read it in a magazine or something
like that are you starting to say you
saw a commercial or it was a TV show but
I changed it to add because it hit
better with my demographic
what's your demographic
uh drunks and sex perverts
incredible guys you've seen Hans Kim
before what'd you think about that
minute Brian Simpson Trapper Wallace
yeah I thought it sounded like you did
at the beginning I was like oh no Hans
yeah can you make rent after you're done
on kill Tony you know that's true you
guys are roommates I didn't even think
about that
these are you're looking at the real
kill Tony fans out here Brian is there
anything about being a roommate with
Hans that you can tell us I mean he's
been a very regular character on the
show for two years I'm sure there's
something people would love to know well
you know look I'm not one to put my
business in the street but I'll just say
it's exactly what you would imagine
I love Hans oh yeah we all do uh Trevor
have you ever seen Hans before uh not
live see him on live I love the outfit
it makes me just want to like vape and
fight a Taco Bell employee you know
Baja Blast some [__] up you know what I
mean thank you Trevor I wore this for
you did you really yeah you got any
Jewel pods on you hell yeah
so hook it up
hell yeah I thought it was great it was
phenomenal minute thank you a good new
minute Hans you know how this goes put
the mic back in the mic stand go back
behind the curtain how about one more
time for Hans Kim we're gonna see him in
just a second he's not gone no that was
Hans Kim music at
guys what you're about to see is again I
mean this is a whole new era of kill
Tony someone fighting for regular ship
to start the show is insane and I can
only give credit to one of my favorite
mentors and heroes the great Vince
McMahon who likes starting shows with a
bang every once in a while I think it
works out great anyway the guy who
you're about to see
has the opportunity to change his
[__] life
he's not a very controversial run on
kill Tony he's on or off I mean it's
either home runs or [__] big missed
swings also has a huge cocaine addiction
um he has great musical abilities a lot
of different things he's fairly fairly
real really new to stand-up comedy I
think only about eight or nine months in
so here he is fighting to become a
regular every single week on the number
one Live Comedy podcast in the world
makes some noise for Uncle laser
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
cuckolding
when one [__] one's wife while one
other watches and or masturbates
not as funny as I thought either it's
not as good as it is he didn't see the
other day in Vegas I got involved in a
cuckolding situation all right I'm
playing slot machines being the
degenerate piece of [__] that I am this
snaggletooth old man walks up to me said
hey man we're big fanciers me and my
wife watch you all the time it'd be an
honor if you would [__] her while I
watch
I said I'm gonna pass my God he goes I'd
be willing to pay you some shekels for
your time
I said all right well let me take a look
at her now
this will the Beast of a woman comes
crawling out under the vending machine
she walks up to me I can hear her
breathing from 20 yards away
she looks leathery like she fell asleep
in a tanning bed
like a [__] Buick seat
I said nah man I'm gonna have to pass he
said I'll give you four thousand dollars
I said I said man to be honest with you
Buick's not that bad of a car I'll take
her for a spin
that's it
well I mean if there's more how much
longer is the thing
another minute 30 seconds that's all you
know the format of the show that's not
that's not fair that's your minute okay
all right Uncle laser all right
okay all week this guy what have you
been saying I'm gonna bury him
I want to bury him with a [__] shovel
meanwhile you're dressed like you just
dug yourself out of a grave look at that
going
on a parole hearing right now
oh my goodness Uncle laser what a
special [__] treat so what can you
just at least tell us separate from the
minute which won't count to the audience
voting but how does the story how's it
end yeah oh so I went up there and uh
when I got up there threw me a curveball
and he's like hey man you can [__] her
but I want to wear your socks while you
do it
and that was very strange to me and I'm
like no like my Mama gave me these socks
these are my lucky socks I'm a Vegas so
he gave me 200 I let him wear my boxers
on his head right and so
I finished you know what I'm saying and
then I took my four thousand dollars I
went to the roulette four thousand
dollars hold on did you use a condom
with this lady no
how long how long did this what are you
talking about I forgot who I was talking
to I'm sorry drink out of a water hose
don't wear it kind of pretty simple dude
right
and you never get sick never get sick
immune uh but I finished and I took my
first hold on I got another question how
long is the whole sexual intercourse
pumping how many 20 25 minutes I feel
like anything over that's over handling
right
and anything under is underperforming
so you always look at that 20 25 minute
window that's the window right that's
the thing you kept your socks on kept my
socks on so then I go down the roulette
table and I put all that four thousand
dollars on black you know what color it
came up what green no way so then I'm
sitting there like well [__] that went
quick so I did with any piece of [__]
degenerate gamble doing if anybody here
has a gambling problem you'll know this
all too well I marched my ass right back
up to that hotel room and I [__] her
again for a thousand dollars I let him
wear my socks
[Laughter]
you gotta learn how to edit the [__]
[__] out dude
you're up there singing [__] Country
music lyrics
yeah I was just about to say you like
the only reason the reason you're gonna
lose the hanzanite is because he's he's
so much experienced more experience than
writing jokes because you could have got
to that in a minute
I realized because you could have just
been
like hey a dude a dude paid me to [__]
his wife she was ugly and then bam right
right I did it for four thousand dollars
you do stand-up comedy like you're
reading a child to bed
and then a wildebeest came from behind
the vending machine
it's just it's you gotta bang you gotta
get to that I want to paint this paint
this story set the mood you know it
doesn't it doesn't work like that in
stand-up comedy there's no painting
moods people come to laugh they don't
come to be like whoa
what a special trip this is
Hans Kim get back out here this is uh
this is gonna be uh
yeah Hans cam has defended his throne
twice already once against golden ticket
winner Enrique Chacon another time
against golden ticket winner and uh
favored almost barely favored a very
even match Jared Nathan this is his
third time defending his regular ship
how many of you have Uncle laser being
the new regular after his performance
tonight Make Some Noise you guys get to
decide
[Music]
[Applause]
it's all the racist people look at all
those mustaches
how many of you have Hans Kim retaining
well Uncle laser we gave you a shot you
put up a fight I hope that you learned
something here you gotta [__] trim
the fat it's the ultimate note it's the
one note that everybody in their first
few years a lot of people have been
doing this [__] 10 years and they're not
editing enough it is the real secret
writing is the most important thing and
then cutting that [__] down to only the
pieces you need is the thing that
separates the goods from the greats so I
think you learned the ultimate lesson
here tonight because you got buried by
Chopsticks you know what I'm saying you
got [__] he put you in a to-go box
with a little metal handle he's gonna
carry you home Hans Kim what do you want
to say I like to present Uncle laser
with his very own little joke book made
by bonsai
makes the noise for Uncle laser
Hans you wanna you wanna say anything
else I'm not surprised [__]
3-0 undefeated
the first ever regular not only to
defend his position once twice but three
times Hans you are undeniable Make some
noise for Hans Kim everything he does
that was Hans camp that was Hans Kim
that was Hans Kim all right I pull the
name out of the bucket